[Music]
today on the dish ice cream that's both
naughty
and nice st louis based clementine's
creamery has won awards and accolades
for its sweet creamy treat
that's of the more traditional or nice
variety
and for the boozy or naughty stuff with
five stores in missouri and a nationwide
following
the only thing that might be richer than
the ice cream itself
is the story behind its founding its
founding and its founder
tamara keith also known as the flavor
[Music]
temptress
that iconic chant of summer was recorded
back in the 1920s
and its message remains frozen in time
welcome to come in times for tamara
keith owner of clementine's creamery in
st
louis that need for ice cream goes well
beyond indulging in it
ice cream changed my life as a child and
i think that's why
i've been so passionate about it the
youngest of five siblings
keith says she grew up in a house full
of love but not a lot of money
after church one sunday i heard other
little kids talking about going for ice
cream
and of course i got excited and i ran
over to my mom and i pulled on her dress
and i said hey you know do we get to go
for ice cream
and the answer was no but when her mom
bought an old ice cream maker at a
garage sale
everything changed that was the way that
we could participate and create that
tradition because my parents couldn't
afford to take us all out
word got out in our church that we were
making homemade ice cream
so all of these families started asking
if they could come to our house
one family would bring the milk another
family would bring the cream
like everyone kind of came together and
brought different things
we made ice cream as a family after
church our whole life growing up all the
way through
until when my mom passed away and then i
kind of took over the tradition
so i have like super happy memories
of my mom um sorry
that's okay there's a lot of emotion in
it yeah
yeah but it's it's really powerful to me
to me ice cream it's the one thing that
so many people have so much emotions
tied into
it's a total equalizer ice cream keith
says
even taught her to think differently and
try new things
she became the first in her family to go
to college
i had worked my way up out of business
school
worked for some fortune 100 companies i
ended up running a 70 million dollar
business
and i ended up in the food industry of
all things i had the dream job
i had the dream career i was making more
money in a year than my dad did in 20.
and it's funny sometimes you get there
and it's not all that it's cracked up to
be
at age 38 while on a girl's trip
keefe had an epiphany i just broke down
and i said i am miserable and i was so
lonely
my really close girlfriend turns to me
and she says quit
and i said what would i do
and my other girlfriend turns to me and
she's like you're always complaining our
neighborhood doesn't have an ice cream
shop
and you make the best ice cream in the
world
she's like why don't you open an ice
cream shop and so literally that weekend
we wrote my business plan put together
my deck ran my financials
and two weeks later i resigned weren't
you scared i was
more scared to not change my life and to
continue being unhappy
keefe took her corporate-built savings
and bet on herself
launching clementine's creamery my
approach to clementines was
i am going to do things different i am
going to make ice cream the way it was
made
50 75 years ago i'm going to open a
micro creamery
and there are people who are saying i
don't know what a micro creamery is i
know what a micro brewery is what's a
micro creamery so think micro brewery
for beer but for ice cream in the
simplest terms the ice cream is made in
small batches by real people
a process we got to see and be a part of
at clementine's st
louis based kitchen it's usually two
people because we're moving quick and we
go between machines
got it it has to be all natural and
anything in it like the gooey butter
cake here in one of clementine's
signature flavors
has to be handmade the ice cream also
has to have
less than 30 percent air mixed in it
might be a little fudge
so can i go back in yeah what a shock
that i put maybe too much in there
and contain more than 16 butter fat
numbers that may be tough to digest
until you take a taste
i mean i'm a kid all over again it's
amazing
and so the butter fat is what coats your
tongue
and allows the flavor to linger in your
mouth
it creates a super satiating effect i'm
not sharing
i'm not sharing with anybody
clementine's flavors take you on
a sensory journey salted cracker caramel
and italian butter cookie
three different kinds of crackers chunks
of deliciousness
oh my god vegan options lemon poppy seed
and coconut chocolate fudge
there's even a naughty line of ice cream
that's alcohol infused
i mean that's a manhattan that is a
manhattan wow
boozy beautiful crisp but that's not all
for keith the experience the emotion
she's trying to create for each customer
starts even before the first scoop
we have crafted an experience for people
who come into our shops
to make it one that's memorable to make
it one that they love
and they open the door and they step
over the magic threshold
they take a breath of the fresh waffle
cones
and they look around and their their
face brightens and they get a smile on
their face that's
before they even take a bite of ice
cream it's before they ever take the
bite of ice cream because they know
once they step over that magic threshold
their life
is going to be better than it was before
just like keefe's i work harder now
than i ever have i work 24 hours a day
seven days a week
but it's different because it's mine and
it's my team
and it's my people and they're my
customers and there you are
thank you absolutely and i'm so proud
of what we're doing and what we're
building and what's that old adage
when you do something you love you never
work another day in your life
and that's how i feel about clementines
what would your mom think of this
i think she would be proud
i think so i think she would be uh
amazed and surprised i think oh
i think so too yeah so i brought you
guys we had sent the gooey butter cake
that i helped to make
it's all really delicious and you know
she she knows how expensive something
like this can be
she could make more money off of it and
chooses to make less
because she wants people to be able to
to try to get this she wants people to
have it doesn't mean it's cheap but you
know
how do you get small batch into
america's hands i mean because you ship
nationwide that's high and by the way
during the pandemic the fact that they
were already shipping helped them
tremendously
because they had that business in place
and that's how they got
similar thing with with plymouth cheese
yeah um and i mean she nailed it in the
piece there and that is it's not just
the ice cream it's the experience
it is it was going to those ice cream
stands when you were a kid with your
parents with your family
and every bite is that way which i will
have maple bourbon
pecan yeah manhattan's there too nice